us-star olaf scholz macht urlaub in
deutschland ex kanzler gerhard schröder
macht offenbar urlaub in moskau das
haben die kollegen von mtv gemäht und
peter thiede ist nicht nur kanzler
urlaubs berater und allgäu experte
sondern auch russland und moskauer
experte schröder in moskau ja nicht
nicht zum ersten mal und wie unser
kollege ralf schuler erfahren hat ist
gerhard schröder mit azerbaijan airlines
gestern hingeflogen als in der ersten
reihe gilt gesehen worden schröder
typisch mit rotwein vorsicht ist er nach
moskau geflogen da ist offensichtlich
wieder im kempinski hotel abgestiegen
und da haben wir ihn ja auch schon im
märz glaube ich war das doch immer noch
im februar noch erwischt als er darauf
angeblicher friedensmissionen aber wie
gesagt gerhard schröder ist im schönen
kempinski visier schöne so in etwa sich
auf seine suite aus die er da mal hat
das ist die welt des pop bereich
außerdem kempinski hotel das ist in
unmittelbarer nähe zu seinem arbeitgeber
nämlich so raffiniert zu dem ölkonzern
dem staatlichen und schräg gegenüber vom
kreml man geht einmal über die große
moskauer brücke oder fährt wie gerhard
schröder und ist mit dem auto in einer
minute drüben im kreml und zu 55 minuten
und jahr schröder ja gut er kann eureka
und das warte aber was kann ja wollen
privat wetter nicht da sein was kann was
kann da vor sich gehen gerhard schröder
kann wieder von sich selber glauben dass
auf einer friedensmission ist nur das
nimmt ihm außer sich selber niemanden
mehr sagt der privat dort ja dann eher
wieder urlaub machen also jetzt schröder
muss wegen der begründung finden um
darüber zu fliegen wahrscheinlich hat
ihn putin antanzen lassen und wird in
irgendwelche pläne einweihen oder ihn
wieder als kanal benutzen um welche
botschaften oder erpressungsversuch an
die deutsche politik zu überbringen die
hat schröder kann man da steht nicht
mehr für voll nehmen grad hat er ja
wieder am gas angedreht putin um uns
natürlich maximal zu verunsichern diese
völlig willkürlichen
reduzierungen von jetzt 40 auf 20
prozent das klingt wir uns immer immer
willkürlich macht aus krimml sicht
absolut absolut sinn weil mir putin ist
bekannt dafür dass er eingefrorene
konflikte markt wo er die tvo die flamme
hohen runter drehen kann und so macht
das hat auch beim gas und er weiß wenn
er den gashahn leicht zu drehte dann
kommt ja panik auf und dann entsteht
eine bestimmte situation hier und auch
angst der menschen vor diesen diesen
winter damit spielt vladimir putin ganz
bewusst es gibt auch
geheimdienstinformationen die auf der
bundesregierung vorliegen dass du mir
putin darauf setzt dass es in einigen
teilen von europa vornehmlich auch in
osteuropa aber vielleicht auch bei uns
im winter zu einer art unruhen kommt
weil die leute ihre rechnung nicht
bezahlen können oder kein gas mehr da
ist weil die wohnung hat wirklichkeit
bleiben putin hat ein problem er muss
bis zum frühjahr irgendwo ne lösung her
kriegen weil im in russland muss
momentan jeder weiterbeschäftigt werden
es gibt eine tatsächlich große schatten
arbeitslosigkeit die leute müssten jetzt
eigentlich in arbeitslosigkeit seien das
verhindert das system es müssen alle
weiterbeschäftigt wenn ihnen
automobilindustrie im tourismussektor
überall wo flaute in ganz russland sind
im ersten quartal 25.000 autos verkauf
von mir nicht aber die leute müssen
weiter beschäftigt werden und das
wirklich zählt an den seiner
finanziellen substanz des kreml und das
machen die leute auch nicht lange mit
weil sie kriegen mit dass ich eigentlich
arbeitslos sind und das übersteht das
land kein jahr mehr
[Musik]